[Music]
all right joining us now with reaction
to the battle for speaker on Capitol
Hill and of course the terror terrorist
attack against Israel and Israel's well
imminent response former Speaker of the
House n Gingrich is with us um I would
assume by the end of the week maybe I'm
wrong maybe I'm overly optimistic that
the issue of speaker is going to be
handled in Washington uh you're a
longtime veteran and my my instincts
right
there well I I think because of the
Israeli War
the pressure on Republicans to really
work overtime and find a solution is
much much greater I mean the whole world
is watching and the American house has
to be able to function so I think Steve
kise won a significant Victory today I'm
sure tonight he's trying to put together
the 217 votes because we have a couple
of absences so 27s a majority uh it's
still uphill there are still people who
are saying oh I really don't want to
vote for him I'm really not ready what
have you but I think Republicans have to
come together and realize whether it's
scalise or somebody else and Steve is a
great guy has been a good Majority
Leader he's a solid conservative um
somebody has to get 217 votes and the
house has to get its act together under
our constitution cuz the world's
dangerous and people like Hamas are not
hanging around waiting for the
Republicans so I hope in the next 24
hours they'll find a way to get to 217
and I hope that by tomorrow afternoon
we'll have speaker Steve kise he won a
straightup fight it was a fair fight uh
with a very good member Jim Jordan uh
and I think that we'll see what actually
happens all right let me ask you U both
of us have known prime minister
Netanyahu for decades both of us have
known him um I don't think there's been
uh a more consistent leader on the world
stage with as much moral clarity as
prime minister Netanyahu he has been
very clear that this response will
change the Middle East forever he's been
very clear that this their pending
response their imminent response will
literally be discussed for Generations I
take him at his word I believe you
probably do
too well look I I think we should all
start with President Biden's very strong
statement yesterday that we are dealing
with pure evil now if the president
meant that then the answer is to defeat
and Destroy Hamas since Gaza has 2
million people in order to minimize
civilian casualties there ought to be
some method for letting virtually all of
them leave Gaza go into the areas that
that are nearby create temporary housing
and temporary conditions and then
methodically destroy Gaza until they
have eliminated every single element of
H of Hamas not a single piece of Hamas
not a single soldier not a single
planter should be alive and I think when
you think about 40 babies in one kaboot
being killed a number of them being
beheaded when you think about women
being raped while their own phones are
being used to send the rape scenes to
their families a grandmother being
killed while her own phone records it so
it can be put on Facebook these people
are evil and I think when you're faced
with evil you have to do what is
necessary not what is reasonable and
what is necessary today is the total
complete destruction of Hamas anything
less than that is in fact a defeat yeah
and they have been warning innocent
people in Gaza leave leave now or you
will die not many countries would take
the time to to warn the innocent to get
out of Harm's Way Israel's been doing
that for days uh former speaker of the
house you will be sitting in studio with
us tomorrow we look forward to having
you here thank you sir for being with us
we appreciate it when we come back V
ramaswami he weighs in on the Hamas
terrorist attack in Israel and bake is
criticizing Republicans we'll tell you
why next as we continue hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else